avec deux mois de retard dans un pays en
pleine crise économique y est politique
le gouvernement tunisien a finalement
dévoilé sa loi de finances pour 2022
malgré de nouvelles mesures sociales à
destination des familles des plus
pauvres les tunisiens vont devoir se
préparer entre autres à une augmentation
des prix des produits de première
nécessité
les précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis bassem chez pis on ne l'attendait
plus et pourtant la loi de finances pour
2022 a enfin été dévoilé par la ministre
des finances si m boukhdhir y adopté
sans débat public ni passage par le
parlement toujours gelé depuis le 25
juillet elle ne semble pas faire
l'unanimité et même le président de la
république a déclaré l'avoir signé sans
conviction écoutez j'ai signé malgré des
réserves car le devoir nous oblige à
doter l'état d'une loi de finances dieu
merci nous l'avons adopté avant le début
de la nouvelle année administrative je
ne suis pas convaincu par certains choix
qui ne sont pas en mesure de répondre
aux revendications du peuple en matière
d'équité fiscale des réserves face à
l'obligation d'imposer aux tunisiens un
plan d'austérité pour un caïd sayed et
qui par son coup de force du 25 juillet
avait redonné espoir à un peuple
affaibli par une crise économique et
sociale sans précédent c'est
principalement vers ces tunisiens qui
aspirait à une relance de l'économie à
une cause de leur pouvoir d'achat que le
gouvernement va se tourner pour boucler
ce trou budgétaire qui avoisine les 3
milliards d'euros soit 6,7 pour cent du
pib l'augmentation du prix de l'essence
de l'alcool du tabac ou encore de la
vignette automobile constituera la
méthode est essentielle pour récupérer
les somme est nécessaire néanmoins ce
projet de loi de finances d'elliant
quelques timides avancées sociales la
nouvelle loi de finances prévoit des
mesures afin de soutenir davantage les
familles les plus nécessiteuses hausse
de la subvention de 180 à 200 dinars
pour les ménages les plus pauvres bourse
d'insertion sociale de 500 dinars pour
les étudiants maintien du prix et des
produits subventionnés comme la farine
l'huile ou encore le pain subvention de
200 dinars sur six mois pour les
salariés du tourisme 6ème book jerry a
estimé que la préparation de ce document
avait été une épreuve difficile pour ce
jeune au gouvernement compte tenu de la
situation économique et financière du
pays pour renflouer les caisses de
l'état et relancer l'économie la tunisie
compte encore et toujours sur la
conclusion d'un accord avec le fmi les
discussions devraient reprendre début
janvier avec à l'appui un programme de
réforme élaboré par plus de 80 experts
tunisiens